nouvelle reconstitution commenter les
différentes scènes de crime d'abord à
son domicile
exercice pas évident pour l'accuser flip
ponsard ce plan photographique il à
nouveau auditionné sur la chronologie
des faits par la présidente de la cour
d'assises de fort de france mais aussi
par les jurés aujourd'hui encore on ça
précise que la victime est venue de son
plein gré à son domicile
à son arrivée il la trouve de son séjour
il évoque la thèse accidentelle
seuls des précisions concernant sont
atteints à la route de la trace en
direction du monde rouge où il abandonne
le corps de france lpm il lui paraît
plus évident a commenté ce matin les
experts parlent de comportement
narcissique d'un manque d'empathie
il déclare que pont ça reste dans une
stratégie de contrôle lorsqu'il aborde
les faits l'espère tic ethic apporte un
nouvel élément est presque dans le rang
comptes datant du 22 septembre de 18 à
la maison d'arrêt bon ça aurait déclaré
les choses se sont envenimées lorsque je
demandais à fond cette pme de me
rembourser mes 400 euros par la menaçant
de le dire à son dépôt interrogé à
nouveau sur ses déclarations
ponsard fond en larmes à la barre du
tribunal